green Jean Pierre the president's spokes
lady she was on MSNBC expressing the
White House's condolences over this
horrific attack by iran-backed militants
on US troops heartfelt condolences go
out to the families uh who lost uh three
three Brave uh three Brave uh three
Brave of three folks who are who are
military folks who are brave who are
always fighting who are fighting on
behalf and of uh this Administration
this is about as bad a response as any
Administration could muster military
folks to stumble over you can't say
troops Fighters Warriors service members
military folks just using colloquial
leftist Community activist lingo who
have fought on behalf of this
Administration zian slip